[Musique]
celui-
ci passe à steve vader
je dois sortir d'ici
je dois sortir de cette petite pièce
sortir en boîte de nuit
[Musique]
ce soir de connivence avec
la boîte de nuit
[Musique]
machine
on voit des gens tout neufs
il y a quelque chose à faire
tu vois n'est-ce pas [Musique] [Musique] nous marchons comme un fantôme nous apprenons des danses de toutes nouvelles danses comme les bombes nucléaires oh n'est-ce pas sauvage [Musique] es-tu toujours en boîte de nuit maintenant ouais
bien sûr bien sûr
ouais tu sembles être en grande forme  forme non d'
accord tu dis que je suis un homme marié
j'ai payé mes impôts
je fais mon travail avec soin c'est vrai
ouais c'est à cause de l'influence de suki
non c'est ma propre idée tu sais que ça vient un
moment où euh
tu sais que c'est bon de grandir  ouais
c'est pas mal
rien de mal c'est vrai que quand tu l'as rencontrée
elle était dans un concert au japon et tu l'as
vue
au premier rang et tu as demandé à un roadie
d'aller lui demander de venir avec toi ouais
c'est vrai
[  Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi as-tu fait qu'il y a
quelque chose dans ses yeux
tu sais que j'aime j'aime  e pour regarder les gens
quand je travaille de toute façon ouais
et euh quelque chose de vivant
là-dedans
ouais un personnage tu sais que
tu en avais marre des filles différentes
tous les soirs
et euh demander 40 dollars pour le taxi et
te laisser des maladies
je pense que je pense que
c'est gentil  c'est un peu idiot et
pas de bon goût d'être toujours
à la
recherche d'affaires ouais alors maintenant tu es
comme
John Lennon Rose tu vis à New York
avec une fille japonaise et tu es
très hétéro non je suis je  je suis assez hétéro
je ne suis pas comme euh
je ne suis pas aa ou je n'ai pas de
règle comme je
ne sais jamais c'est du vin ouais tu sais tu
sembles être en pleine forme ouais
tu joues au golf je joue  avec mon père juste comme
quelque chose que
vous savez que nous sommes tous les deux des hommes et et il est
beaucoup plus âgé que moi et donc quand nous nous
réunissons,
nous ne voulons pas vraiment nous asseoir et discuter vous
savez comme oh salut ravi de vous voir alors nous
jouons au golf  pour quelque chose à faire ensemble
est-il vrai que ton père a toujours des
idées de chansons quand tu joues au golf avec
lui et  d il dit oui
j'ai une carte d'identité et tu dis non papa non non
ouais il essaie constamment de me vendre
ses idées de chansons
ouais ouais et tu places euh golf avec
ton fils eric non
non euh-euh mais je vois qu'eric était beaucoup  quand je
vais à hollywood, c'est un gamin d'hollywood,
il chante sur l'une des chansons d'
un nouveau disque qu'il chante et le
nouvel album invaincu brique par brique ouais
avec environ 15 autres gars ouais tu sais
c'est comme un tas de gars dont
tu as parlé  ton nouvel album c'est la chose la
plus
articulée que j'ai faite depuis l'idiot
en 77 ouais ouais quand je l'ai fait
quand j'ai fait l'idiot euh david bowie a
composé toute la musique
et la plupart de la musique pour ça et
je travaillais très dur juste pour me
concentrer sur  les paroles et
cette fois j'ai mis autant de travail dans
les paroles et j'ai aussi
écrit la musique ouais mais j'ai juste travaillé
plus dur en gros
ouais tu sais simple comme ça vraiment tu
as deux gars de gun and roses aussi tu
sais euh-huh
ouais et toi tu  chante un duo avec
un bonbon
ta voix vole comme un
a  irplane comme un b52 je suppose
et son album tu joues de la guitare aussi oui la
toute première fois
j'ai toujours écrit dessus avant mais mon style
est très brut
et euh j'ai toujours embauché plus de professionnels
et celui-ci je me suis en quelque sorte amusé à jouer
avec chacun différent  le guitariste qui a
invité
et a senti que c'était plus réel parce que
souvent le chanteur du groupe
est souvent dans une position frustrée ouais
parce qu'il n'a pas l'instrument
vous savez et il n'a aucun contrôle sur vous
savez ce qui se passe donc parfois c'est
vraiment sympa  pour le ramasser et
ça vient de toi au début tu
étais un batteur
ouais et puis quand tu as vu jim morrison
ou mick jagger
tu as décidé d'être un chanteur eh bien je
voulais être un chanteur
ouais mais c'est quand j'ai vu ces gars
qui  j'étais plus
poussé c'était comme si je ne pouvais plus attendre
c'est ridicule
tu sais quand tu étais enfant tu
vivais à
ypsilanti près de hannah plus près de détroit ouais et
tes parents vivaient
dans un camp de roulottes oui et est-ce vrai
que  toi  jouent de la
batterie dans la caravane c'est vrai ouais
mais où dans la
caravane il y avait une grande chambre ouais et une
chambre principale pour eux
assez grande pour puis une chambre plus petite
pour moi et quand j'ai eu ma batterie
ils ont abandonné leur chambre ouais  oui et
ils ont sorti toutes leurs affaires de leur
chambre et m'ont donné cette chambre
pour me permettre de jouer ce sont
des gens très très merveilleux
et ils ont dormi dans une très très petite pièce
et ils l'ont fait pendant
euh trois ans tout au long du lycée
et  quand je
jouais, tout tremblait et ça
faisait un gros bruit
mais ils étaient toujours vraiment bons à
ce sujet vraiment vraiment euh
chanceux à ce moment-là tu soutenais
les yankees de new york
oui oui je ne peux pas y croire
j'ai vraiment aimé ils  étaient une équipe de classe
vous savez qu'ils avaient
ils avaient tout ce qu'ils avaient du pouvoir ils
avaient de la
vitesse ils avaient euh ils avaient des
cerveaux mais la plupart ils avaient une grande
personnalité cette équipe qu'ils avaient
et vous avez même rejoint les scouts à
cette époque c'est vrai j'étais un  petit sco  ut
mais j'ai été expulsé du scout louveteau
pour avoir fait ça avec les élastiques
tu sais aux réunions est-il vrai
qu'un jour
ton père et ta mère
écoutaient
sinatra à la radio et ton père a
dit que
les gens du show business sont l'aristocratie
de ce pays tu sais
magasiner les artistes sont les nouveaux
aristocrates
de ce pays ouais et j'ai écouté et
puis tu as décidé d'être une star eh bien j'étais
déchiré entre
je voulais vraiment être un politicien
et j'étais vraiment intéressé
par ça mais comme je  a commencé à jouer,
c'était beaucoup plus amusant de jouer que de
s'asseoir et de parler et aussi
Kennedy a été abattu et quand il a été abattu, je
pense
que beaucoup de gens en Amérique sont devenus plus
cyniques
ouais et un peu comme hé attendez une minute
quelque chose ne va pas
vous le savez donc  ça m'a en quelque sorte rebuté et
ton premier groupe s'appelait les iguanes
et c'est pourquoi ton nom était ton vrai
nom n'est pas iggy pop
james ouais d'accord et puis tu as décidé
de t'appeler
iggy j'avais un surnom c'était un surnom toi  ah d'
autres personnes m'ont appelé comme ça et puis
finalement j'ai juste abandonné
ouais d'accord et maintenant j'aime ça tu sais et
comment
as-tu rencontré les frères ashton ron était
dans un groupe local et c'était un bon bassiste
vraiment bon et son frère j'étais  un
batteur j'étais en
quelque sorte l'un des meilleurs batteurs de la
ville et son frère
était que ça traînait et
me regardait jouer du tambour et finalement un jour a dit
tu sais que j'aimerais apprendre le
drame m'apprendrais-tu et tu as commencé les faire-
valoir
ouais tu as été influencé par les rois
le woo
les pierres les portes ouais mais beaucoup plus
détruit
et aussi par aussi par
toute la musique qui sortait du
genre du croissant du moyen-orient j'ai
remarqué que
certains des groupes que j'aime utilisaient l'
américain  blues ouais et je pensais bien
que la source s'est tarie allons plus
loin de chez nous
et tu as été influencé par le froid en
essayant extrêmement beaucoup
extrêmement par coltrane euh j'ai toujours
et aussi shep et albert ayler ouais et
euh vraiment ces trois là étaient comme le
trinity
et j'ai toujours senti que j'avais toujours senti que
j'essayais d'utiliser mon
corps comme ils utiliseraient leur
saxophone euh lyriquement dans ma
livraison de chant c'était plus
tu sais jagger dylan lou reed
tu sais essayer d'essayer d'imiter ces
gars qui étaient mon  héros donc vous étiez les
premiers punks
en 67 vous vous appelez le parrain
c'est vrai je ne sais pas
mais 10 ans plus tard quand le pistolet sexuel
euh a chanté pas de plaisir
vous n'aviez plus de groupe à cette époque non
où vous étiez triste d'être seul à ça  le temps
et de n'avoir aucun groupe
ii ne pouvais pas je ne me suis jamais assis et
j'ai pensé que j'aimerais que nous soyons ensemble
quelque chose comme ça
je suis trop réaliste il y avait une
raison pour laquelle ça s'est terminé
et quand ça s'est terminé ça s'est terminé euh ouais c'est
solitaire
parfois être un solo ouais c'est
solitaire d'un autre côté le
groupe être dans un groupe
a beaucoup de tension aussi les groupes se
séparent les gens meurent
ouais euh beaucoup de fois euh
quelqu'un d'autre attrape quelqu'un tu sais des
choses  arriver
donc tu étais le premier t  o portez
des jeans
jusqu'aux genoux tu as été le premier
à déchirer mon jean bleu ouais mais
je ne les ai pas coupés en premier comme les autres est-
ce que tu as sauté sur tes
genoux j'étais
tellement à genoux qu'ils ont commencé à déchirer  et j'ai
pensé wow ça a l'air plutôt cool tu
sais que tu es le premier à abuser de
ton corps avec des bouteilles en verre aussi non je
ne l'ai fait que
deux fois ouais euh ouais et ce n'était pas
une expérience heureuse je l'ai juste fait parce que
euh
j'ai été très très déçu ouais à
ce moment particulier
et c'est juste arrivé j'étais le premier
à plonger en scène
ouais aussi je suis un peu fier de ça
parce que beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
s'amusent à faire ça
tu sais vraiment tu sais  tu sais donc
ton premier album le premier
euh album des stooges a été produit par euh
et il était comme une baby-sitter pour toi
parce qu'il te laissait faire
ce que tu voulais faire non si si on avait
essayé de faire ce qu'on faisait
sans personne pour le justifier  à l'entreprise
nous aurions eu un gâchis
mais ils ils pour certains  raison pour laquelle ils
lui ont fait confiance je ne pense
pas je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est vrai qu'il était
pendant les séances
il était habillé comme un dracula ouais ouais
il s'habillait
comme bien pas totalement dracula mais il
portait dans ma mémoire
il portait un grand  longue cape noire avec un gros
truc comme ça
et il avait l'air plutôt cool et nico
venait aux séances de temps en temps
ouais tu étais l'amant de nico pas à ce
moment-là
elle t'a dit sexe j'ai entendu n'importe quoi et
et
et elle tricotait ouais tu sais
elle tricotait pendant qu'on jouait cette
musique très forte
ton deuxième album était fun house et puis
avec le groupe
toi tu es tombé très bas dans les champignons
cocaïne héroïne et c'était bad trip pour
toi
quelle est la pire chose que tu aies faite à ce
moment là
pour trouver l'été  la pluie une fois que j'en ai marqué,
j'étais dans une voiture de location que je n'avais pas
payée et
je ne pouvais pas l'emmener là où je l'avais marqué et
j'étais tellement impatient de le prendre que
je suis allé je me suis arrêté dans une station-service
où  et je suis allé dans les toilettes des hommes et
il y avait un
cendrier que vous n'aviez pas  o j'ai quelque chose à
cuisiner
ouais le cendrier était très sale et donc
beaucoup de saleté s'y est
mis et j'ai eu une très mauvaise réaction
euh ce n'est pas très c'est très douloureux de
parler de
ce genre de choses ouais
alors tu as rencontré tony le  frites parce que
bowie était déjà intéressé par toi
et tu t'as amené au
bureau de bus cbs et est-il vrai que la
première fois que tu es venu
tu as chanté une chanson sinatra sur les mains et les
genoux
honnêtement ouais le bureau de la petite amie les mains
et les genoux et disant
ombre ton sourire un  un peu de ma
drôle de Saint-Valentin
ouais ouais ouais et puis ça a mal tourné
parce que tu ne voulais
pas devenir une star quand tu as vu David
Bowie à ce moment-là
tu ne voulais pas devenir comme lui non
c'est une déclaration assez juste je
le respectais
et euh mais j'avais quelque chose à moi
que je
voulais vraiment vraiment faire et je
savais en quelque sorte à l'
avance qu'ils avaient d'autres plans pour moi, il était
difficile d'émettre de la puissance brute
parce que tu es allé à los angeles et tu es
entré  un hôpital
et y  tu étais juste autorisé à sortir
pour chanter sur le disque et puis tu es
revenu
et tu sais que c'était sur un disque plus tard
donc nous avons passé un très mauvais moment
la seule chose que nous avons réussi à enregistrer était
un album appelé kill city
et ça  était celui où j'ai fait le
chant le week-end parce que j'étais dans un
hôpital ouais, ce qui était essentiellement je l'ai
fait pour mon bien
ouais parce que j'ai réalisé que tu n'étais
plus capable de te gérer c'est pas
pour prendre soin de toi je ouais  c'est
vrai je ne savais plus comment
j'avais perdu la capacité ouais ouais donc comme
beaucoup de gens
oui ouais en 1976 tu es allé à berlin avec
david bowie pour finir l'idiot ouais
que tu avais commencé dans le nouveau
village ouais et toi  passé du bon temps là-bas
ouais rock and
roll c'était un grand tu sais c'est une grande grande
ville physiquement c'est énorme
ouais et il a été construit pour beaucoup plus de
gens qu'il n'y vivait il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de monde là-bas alors c'était vraiment
vide
et le  les gens qui étaient là ils étaient
très marginaux
ve  ry au bord de la vie et beaucoup d'
insoumis
qui fuient l'armée beaucoup
d'étudiants
et d'artistes étranges restants étaient dans la
discothèque
de berlin  en
tournée
avec david et je sortais juste
tous les soirs avec lui sortir
tous les soirs tous les soirs juste aller disco
disco tous les night club club club
et donc c'était l'idée de ça ce n'était pas
censé être sur ce
disque c'était le  l'enregistrement était presque terminé et
lui et moi et un de ses amis étions
juste en train de faire des gaffes dans le studio
et il a mis l'un de ces masques en caoutchouc
d'un
très vieil homme d'un vieil homme
et courait partout et il s'est assis au
piano et  a commencé à jouer une
sorte de musique de vieil homme comme hoagy
carmichael ouais
et il joue cette musique et j'ai
basculé et j'ai dit que c'était génial parce
que j'ai toujours
eu la capacité de reconnaître la musique chez les
autres
c'est vous savez c'est un peu ce que je  je suis
bon et
et je viens  Je suis allé whoa c'est génial s'il vous plaît
je peux faire une parole cela peut être génial
je ne suis pas si bon mais je l'ai convaincu
et donc nous l'avons fait
et puis il a pensé que le tambour le
talent de la boîte à rythmes sonne trop bon marché
parce que ça  était comme une boîte à rythmes 98
mais j'ai vraiment aimé la façon de couper aussi tu as
dit à propos de berlin que le mur
protégeait la ville de toutes les agressions
du monde c'est ce que je ressentais ouais
surtout parce que nous avions été tu sais que
lui et moi vivions à los  angeles,
il était un peu plus au-dessus et
j'étais au-dessous,
mais à berlin, c'était la première ville
où j'étais allé où les gens ne se sont pas simplement penchés et n'ont pas
embrassé le cul du rock and roll pour
la mauvaise raison
qu'est-ce que david bowie t'a
apporté m'a excité à je n'ai jamais vraiment su le
ballet
ouais il m'a excité et oginski et
diagolev
et euh toute l'histoire du ballet
se perche toute l'
idée toute l'idée d'artistes de différentes
disciplines
travaillant ensemble et il  toute l'idée que
personne n'a jamais dit  moi hé tu sais que tu
pourrais être peintre
ouais parce que je ferais ces petits
dessins et tu devrais peindre alors il
m'a montré comment préparer une toile
parce qu'il avait été à l'école d'art tu sais
m'a montré à chaque fois qu'il était là tu
sais à chaque fois  tu as eu des problèmes
et euh il était tu sais que c'est une
personne
qui travaille très dur et ça a déteint parce que j'avais l'habitude d'être
assez paresseux trop indulgent
ouais et je pensais que Dieu ce gars travaille
dur tu sais que ça
pourrait être une bonne leçon et quoi
pensez-vous qu'il y a longtemps
qu'avez-vous apporté à david bowie je
ne peux pas dire
que je serais pour lui de dire je ne sais pas
mais sans iggy nozigi
évidemment évidemment ii suppose que oui
semble avoir une
partie de mon  nom là-dedans et un jour
après ça,
Elton John voulait te produire et il
t'a offert
euh cinq cent mille dollars une maison
sur la colline
non et tu as dit quand je l'ai regardé j'ai
vu
des glaciers scandaleux sauvages et et un fait
derrière eux
ce n'est pas  qui s'intéressait à nous
à un moment donné  nt
euh je ne sais pas à quel point il était intéressé mais il
aimait vraiment
james ouais williamson tu sais
qu'il avait un faible pour james et euh ça
n'est jamais allé nulle part tu sais que tu es une
légende j'aime juste faire une bonne chanson
que
quelqu'un t'aime  tu penses que tu
aurais pu être plus grand sans
drogue et sans drogue je n'ai aucun moyen de le dire
mais je veux dire que je suis plus grand que je ne l'
étais l'année dernière ouais donc tu sais que je vais bien